[Applaudissements]
la l'interrompt surprise aussi un qui va
arriver floride années 90 ans la voilà
je vous je fais des footings et du
footing
oui on a des petites salles
ça nous fait plaisir de te revoir
oui non mais c'est vous le pensez c'est
bien que tu passes un jour tu repars
quand la demande est bien sûr évoqué
décidé comme toi c'est vous qui décidez
[Rires]
donnez lui un indice pour de magrin oui
un petit indice voyager jeudi demain
tous - puis joe cole jeudi des noms de
fichiers mais là ça va venir me connais
je voulais en venir à l'antenne mais il
vient bien sûr tu sera là demain mon bac
si ça marche ça me fait très plaisir oui
vous avez une question plutôt merci ben
ali moi j'ai une question pour vous à la
réduction dans la rue allez c'est parti
bonjour je m'appelle simone sur twitter
cyril hanouna a annoncé qu'il
réfléchissait déjà à la saison prochaine
et qu'il avait bien écouter les
téléspectateurs
donc je n'ai pas de question mais je
voulais dire que jamais chez les maximes
gainey va beaucoup me manquer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un avis réponse je comprends votre
rester simone et mais je pense qu'il ya
un malentendu
jean michel et maxime sont loin d'être
sur le départ bien au contraire je peux
vous rêvez un scoop énorme pas un scoop
it au rachitique jean michel travaille
sur un projet de biographie de notre
maître à tous non il est très avancé
devrait sortir avant l'été ce intitulé
sobrement j'ai côtoyé un dieu oui ça
sera un ouvrage très mesuré réalisé à
partir d'entretiens que cyril et en
exclusivité j'ai pu me procurer un leurs
échanges pour vous comprenez bien le
projet alors je signale que la voix
féminine à la fin on la voit pas mais
c'est agathe et qu'a priori son
témoignage ne sera pas retenue dans le
bouquin
[Musique]
je vais dire au sérieux et sexy les uns
vrai que toi il avait également mis une
bonne question mais là non plus on y
pose à moi d où s prison preneur en
motivation pour faire c'est vrai parce
que d'habitude les légendes sont mortes
ou non
l'histoire des jeux a tout gagné il faut
savoir que je m'échauffe et jean michel
baert toutes les plus bas oui enfin
c'est pas très difficile de le choix et
jean-michel j'adore répondre rapidement
gb mais là tu vas te [ __ ] de ma gueule
encore comme un roc dans mon post je
sais pas qui en est le respect valérie
lopez y croient je ne sais pas il pas
que je suis dans son délire mais j'aime
bien continuer et dans cet ouvrage jean
michel rendra aussi hommage à un truc
qui force l'admiration tout le monde
la qualité des relances de cyril après
les magnétos si enfin il parlera de ce
convoi l'antenne comme ici et que marie
myriam 1 tarbes anne marie myriam
dernière gagnante française de
l'eurovision
c'était aussi le dernier quart d'un
frère
[Applaudissements]
c'est la barre 3,77 à fait depuis 1977
qu'on n'a pas gagné l'eurovision étaient
très hautes comme mon délire mais allez
allez pas mal elle est pas mal
[Musique]
qui porte la robe les oiseaux les bonnes
[Rires]
[Musique]
et bonne mon frère
[Applaudissements]
c'est la barre 3,77 à fait depuis 1977
qu'on n'a pas gagné l'euro vit parce que
vous réussissez enchères remarquablement
ben je parlais de la robe
on a vu à couper dans mes jolies parce
que marie g j'aime beaucoup mais ça
n'est pas mon délire personnel alors que
l'europe c'était votre délire mystique
[Rires]
alors pour revenir à la question de
départ sous la pression de certains
chroniqueurs je vous rassure à la
rentrée vous pourrez toujours apprécié
l'érudition de maxime gainey qui est
sans doute celui qui a fait le plus
avancé des missions depuis le début la
wii par ses scoops déjà mais aussi grâce
à la qualité de son vocabulaire
j'ai fait le calcul depuis début de la
saison c'est lui qui a le plus bonifier
la langue française en inventant des
mots qu'on ne connaissait pas mais que
j'ai essayé de vous traduire les
nouveaux mots de maxime kenny
mais rappelez vous je crois qu'à une
certaine époque elle courait à peu les
paparazzis dpp ready paparazzi peu
agressif pépère des voix devant les
magazines people ça va être devant en
kiosque un kiosque kiosque qui a mal au
cul maxime j'aime beaucoup ce programme
inédit leur est absent un programme
diluerait programme un peu foufou
exemple le bipe digues ou v8 est bien
ici c'est toujours très équilibré du
fait d'avoir un multiple de points de
vue une multiplient du sud
multitude augmenté grâce à un ampli et
parce que c'est une assise et une
incitation à la consommation
non seulement d'alcool de tabac le tap a
produit qu'on met dans les cigarettes
mais c'est ça voulait dire oui surtout
que c'est une émission de relooking une
émission de relooking émission où les
genres luc hyprocrite engagement que
doivent prendre les chroniqueurs avant
de passer à la télé le serment
d'hypocrite effet dû se racontent une
histoire laisse m'avait permis
laisse-moi pearl et laisse-moi enfiler
des perles synonyme de faire des phrases
pour rien quand on n'est pas d'accord
avec toi on dit n'importe quoi
alors on est 60 millions de francs c'est
à dire d'un bond de 60 millions de
français version optimiste du nombre de
gens séduisants en france promettent de
l'extrême on trouve la nouvelle
génération elles sont postés sur twitter
and sensibles s'abstenir
des âmes sensibles âme qu'on peut
griller au barbecue exemple les sauts
cible de strasbourg
un premier mieux pourquoi je sais
d'articuler je suis très bien à change
rien j'adore ça ça va être ça s'arrête à
rigaud gagner votre place qui
s'emboîtent chaque fois qu'il vient pas
un jour et croit qu'il est c'est normal
il venait tous les jours parce qu'en
fait je vous le dis parce qu'il ya
maximy n'est pas mieux trois lots je
vous dis c'est normalement son contrat
c'est deux fois par semaine on s'est
rendu compte avec le comptable c'est le
mec qui venait tous les jours donc il
nous a coûté un oseille cambrai et a
jamais rien dit à personne j'avais un
contrat de 10 ans parle jamais rien dit
non mais je me suis très bien qu'on
tenait à l'aise
arrête toi tu recevais des chèques non
pas toi pas s'emmerder non plus la bravo
alors le complément de ma semaine
maintenant on doit à marcher castaldi
n'ont ainsi alors franchement je crois
que le compliment de l'année il a fait à
brigitte lahaie dans quoi il s'est
embarqué
on sent qu'il est gentil et que notre
invité alors pour lui rendre hommage
il va commencer par lui parler de son
travail et puis après c'est free style
alors qui est une ancienne actrice de
films x et qui maintenant ont fait des
remarques à la démission à la radio ou
l'autre tu sens que le torrent du
malaise est au bout de la phrase de
benjamin est trop tard il est parti tout
seul sur son petit canot et je connais
je connais très bien les gîtes d'abord
je trouve que dans ces émissions elle
permet aux gens de s'exprimer ce qui est
plutôt une bonne chose elle parle de
sexe très très très librement et moi je
le geipan de dire gg
plus beaucoup de ces films quand j'étais
beaucoup plus jeune oh c'était encore
des vhs et j'en avais quelques facettes
et pas moi qui les ai laissés c'était
mon grand père mais t'as vu les piquer
dans la vie
on trouve
pour l'habitat la nuit
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien vous choque pas j'ai bien
recevoir 10 alors m
ma fille qu'on vide ans après elle m'a
dit que mon grand père n'avait chiner
mais ces montants r oui ça oui mais en
fait de lui son grand père c'est yves
montand la ccin bercy ça donne sur le
film i comme icare
je ne savais pas merci à vous savez pas
et bah écoute et oui alors oui bah bon
une alchimie quoi y'a quoi il ya eu des
inquiétudes
j'ai pas eu les détails mais peut-être
que c'est d'accord un bel hommage à ton
grand père l'a formé à cette émission
cette semaine à l'est en tout cas c'est
magnifique transition pour passer au top
gène ans avec encore une fois une
compilation des petits moments
indéfinissable de tpm paix et on
commence par mon ami m'a peep-toe
legrand mokhtar
[Musique]
à l'occasion de la sortie de son livre
fut sentout passe à paraître après nous
avons choisi hier soir sur france 2
s'est sentie
[Musique]
une amie de taxi
mal renseignés à mon papa m'aime petit
mari je parle de toi
ses petites manies petit mari insiste
oui la bresle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cet achat de jeux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
vraiment
l'eau
[Musique]
les chés hashtag castaldi est une
ballade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on voit le vrai collier la différence
copain pascal et le gars que ni la
production sur tout ce qui s'est passé
dans l'émission
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup
non mais c'est ouais j'aime beaucoup
zidane là c'est un génie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors gare sud et dylan qui viennent 68
ça sera plus rapide
j'aime beaucoup jaloux non mais bien de
montrer ses pairs ou déjà beaucoup
zidane
bah alors cessé de la drague en live sa
personnalité pas du tout mais alors d'où
vient à l'esprit
oui je serais vous n'avez pas dix images
que l'on connaît par coeur l'histoire
insubordination côté alors j'aimerais
que dylan revient la semaine prochaine
comme il annoncé mais par contre
invité par jean luc lahaye en même temps
non franchement vous sinon parler lui un
petit peu à quoi il va parce que le
débat sur koh lanta je crois qu'il a pas
qui fait de ouf on entendit l'année
était très clair dans ses explications
il ya quelques trois jours moi j'étais
au poteau et vous ne donnez pas autant
et moi j'ai voulu mettre les choses au
clair comme ça il fait pas pression
personne n'y a plus personne qui ait
plus de pression en personne qui
ce que
pour tous chaque chroniqueur c'est
surtout chez toi
non
obama
[Musique]
mon souci
sur moi et
je viens fin de l'année voilà on a on a
tourné la page
j'ai donné mon explication pour le
bénévolat c'est à lui que tu veux pas le
regarder
ils n'ont pas regardé le gall méchante
et qu'il était très bien il soufflait il
était agacé
ouais je sais ça j'en prends encore là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
encore ses chansons nara fabian caterina
sont pas allés allez on commence par
matthieu delormeau qui rigolaient à
l'instant et qui est qui avait profité
de la venue de virginie ledoyen allait
faire croire sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'il était ami avec des stars
j'étais souvent les mêmes droits comme
ceux qui veulent bien qu'on est gay
[Musique]
merci
m
je peux danser
[Musique]
et comme anita rien quand il sort
yamani qui empruntera plus froid ça qu
on sait comment on appelle à qui l'homme
de ma vie le train fantôme
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a du strike
oui
[Applaudissements]
à 108,5 réveiller vos raisonnements
un petit coucou à gaza
ça n'est pas pédaler mais c'est fait
draguer par george clooney s'est attaqué
par jean pierre descombes
[Musique]
sur des images du président au foyer par
l'elysée miskine
[Applaudissements]
moi ici sur le plateau il ya un mec à
regarder dans mon cul me souviens
devenir de meilleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la
q
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]